question what's the best
boston movie of all time
oh my god we got the town
we got the we got the departed i love
the town you got the one where damon
wayne's
plays on the jazz and the two celtics
fans kidnapped
there's some great ones what's the other
one with um mystic river mystic valley
river
uncut gems casey affleck's stars in the
other one uh gone baby what is it gone
baby
baby gone isn't that in boston there's a
lot of good boston movies
the town the town love the town let's
give the flowers to the town right now
yeah the town's an amazing movie shout
out to ben affleck
top five historical boston figure of all
time let's give some flowers to ben
affleck
facts shout out shout out to jlo he's
yeah she's back
hey man anytime i i love to see when a
white boy catches him a
beautiful woman just you know outside of
our ring i'll be like ben you're back in
there you're making us look good bro
i see you man anyway look be it thank
you for pulling up
um yeah the new song's out you got lots
of music out go support you're gonna
have a crazy rest of the year
for certain for certain so much bullet
cab i love being here and i love my
gifts
and i'm coming back so it is done done
deal and then next time
get your dog situated so your dog could
be in here yeah i mean we could have me
in the interview
would it be to be in mia she's chilling
today look at her
it's lit